[Music]
many years ago this Scandal blessed our
family with a miracle our house our
Casita came to life with magic
[Music]
in time every member of our family
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh I understand you I'm not super
strong like Luisa so don't be stuck
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
why am I the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with another con
queso
[Music]
magic is in danger we gotta get out of
here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance I will save the magic
wait how do I say the magic
[Music]
the fate of the family is gonna come
down to you I can't do this let me help
you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
Even in our darkest moments
respective
[Music]
but at least I'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend I want
you to meet forky
he's a spoiled yes yeah I know
Forkey is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him Woody we
have a situation I am not a toy I was
paid for soup salad maybe chili and then
the trash
plus we've got to get 14. oh
why am I alive your Bonnie's toy you are
going to help create happy memories that
will last for the rest of her life
huh what oh
oh
oh Barky come on Bobo hi there my name
is Gabby Gabby we can't stay yes you can
boy
oh what are you doing here no time to
explain come with me we need to get back
to our kid oh Sheriff Woody always
coming to the rescue Bonnie needs 4K
Woody who needs a kid's room when you
can have all of this WOW Wendy aren't we
going to Bonnie
we have to we have to find them what
would he do jump out of a moving vehicle
let's go you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could open your eyes
Woody there's plenty of kids out there
sometimes change can be good you can't
teach this old toy New Tricks you'd be
surprised
honey we're going home Porky
I was made to help a child I don't
remember it being this hard Woody
somebody's whispering in your ear
okay
[Music]
summer in the city of Arendelle
it couldn't be warmer it couldn't be
sunnier but that's about to change
forever
Arendelle it's completely Frozen
a real howler in July yeah
covered in Italian
don't do something soon we'll all freeze
to death you want to talk about a
problem I sell ice for a living oh
that's a rough business to be in right
now I mean that is really that's
unfortunate
Lady
this is awkward not you're awkward but
just because we're I'm awkward you're
gorgeous wait what hi everyone I'm Olaf
hi you're creepy well I don't want it no
we got off to a bad start
I know how to stop this winter
hang on I like fast whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa get your feet down this is fresh
lacquer seriously were you raised in a
barn
let's go bring that summer
man am I out of shape
stop
whoa whoa are you okay I've got a thick
skull I don't have a skull
Head Rush so cute it's like little
Beanie unicorn
s my sister that would have been nice to
know
it is not nice to throw snow people oh
feisty pants just let the Snowman be I'm
calm great
some people are worth melting for you're
just moving out right this second
come on buddy faster no here
hang in there guys
[Applause]
I give you my legs I can't feel my legs
those are my legs oh hey do me a favor
grab my butt oh that feels better
meet the residents of element City
air usually has their head in the cloud
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy
nothing weird going on here uh just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
oh
fire
we run a little hot
[Music]
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
elements cannot mix
pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
you've never left firetown sorry buddy
elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
does anyone get to tell you what you can
do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
Amber I see a change in you
what hair guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes but I never once asked what I
wanted to do
write this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
[Music]
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is Raya our
lands have been at War for as long as we
can remember our people never see eye to
eye
my daughter I believe our people can
come together again but someone has to
take the first step now in order to
restore peace we must find The Last
Dragon I wish to join this Fellowship of
particularly
let's go
let's watch our backs
six years of searching please let this
be it
oh my DC too who said that we really
need your help I'm gonna be real with
you I'm not like the best dragon have
you ever done like a group project but
there's like that one kid who didn't
pitch in as much but still ended up with
the same grave
uh we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
I have to take the first step
I just shape changed dragons can do that
look how close my butt is to my head
it's digestion so much faster in
theaters or order it on Disney plus with
Premiere access March 5th
[Music]
for Generations this peaceful island has
been home to our family but beyond our
Reef a great danger is coming
Legend tells of a hero who will journey
to find the demigod Maui
and to and together
to save us all
[Applause]
Maui
a boat
[Music]
Maui
the demigod of the Wind and Sea I am
hero of man what it's actually Maui
shapeshifter demigod of the Wind and Sea
hero of men I interrupted from the top
hero of men go
I'm not going on a mission with some
little girl this is my canoe and you
will Journey the difference
did not see that coming the ocean is a
friend of mine
first we've got to go through a whole
lotion of bad
fuckamora
I got your back it's Maui time
wow really blow dart in my butt cheek
[Music]
of monsters don't worry it's a lot
farther down than it looks
[Music]
[Applause]
zootopia a gleaming City
where animals of all breeds predator and
prey alike live together in peace and
Harmony hi I'm Judy your new neighbor
yeah well we're loud don't expect us to
apologize for it zpd's first rabbit
officer Judy Hopps ready to make the
world a better place
bad news in this city gripped by fear
what can you tell us about the animals
that went Savage
this is Priority One humps parking Duty
that's her I'm not just some token bunny
you should try cow you resign deal
[Music]
then they should have gotten a real cop
to solve it you are under arrest for
what hooding a free Wings you are a key
witness no he is
hey I need you to run a plate all right
I know a guy you need something done
he's on it they're all slots
we are in a really big hurry I am
on it break
I have 36 hours left we can only solve
it together it's not about how bad you
want something it's about what you are
capable
never let them see that they get to you
you bunnies so emotional do not let go
but leave them we are still animals quit
it you're gonna start a howl no
you are naked for sure we're a
naturalist Club all the way down
[Music]
[Applause]
Life's a little bit messy
[Music]
we all make mistakes
[Applause]
no matter what type of animal you are
change starts with you we gotta go the
most feared Crime Boss Mr Big
[Music]
stop stop talking huh
what did we say no I think one at my
wedding I have to maybe Daddy has to
[Music]
far away as North as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you've seen
Enchanted Forest yes
it was a magical place but something
went wrong since then no one can get in
or out
Papa that was epic
what would I do without you you'll
always have me
has Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
s
the kingdom is not safe
find who is calling to you they may have
answers I'm going with you Anna no
excuse me I climbed to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming
that's normal
where are we
how did you get in the forest the missed
parted for us impossible where did you
learn
[Music]
you can't just follow me into fire then
don't run into fire
[Music]
without you she may lose herself to it
protect Arendelle at all costs I Believe
In You Elsa more than anyone or anything
[Music]
quick question is the hope putting us
Immortal danger gonna be a regular thing
[Music]
am I right
it's gonna be the best year ever and
nothing's gonna get in my way all right
oh
[Music]
maybe breakfast is ready
It's Gonna be Me
is everything okay
monster
[Applause]
[Music]
this happened already what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas
you're so cute sick I've always wanted a
tail I'm a freak we love you Mae you are
a girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotions will release the
panda Abby hit me
[Music]
oh
o m u
my whole life I've been perfect little
Maymay but maybe I like this new me
Mama's girl
this is the first test of my robotics
project
the seventh test
this is Tadashi my older brother 33rd
test
this is the 84th test hello I am Baymax
it works oh this is amazing I wanted to
help a lot of people
people keep saying she's not really gone
as long as we remember him
[Music]
hello I am Baymax Tadashi programmed me
to heal the sick and injured
you will be all right there there
would like to help scan complete your
experiencing mood swings diagnosis
puberty whoa what it's like spooning a
warm marshmallow reports are flooding in
about a major catastrophe Runner attack
from a super villain people come on go
go go go I am not fast
so a man in a kabuki mask attacked you
and ballooned me
[Music]
we gotta catch him we can't go against
that guy we're nerds trust me I know
about robotics we can be way more
anybody else's suit riding up on him
come on kick it down
why is Baymax wearing carbon fiber
Underpants this may undermine my
non-threatening huggable designs
it's glorious
that was a terabyte of heights I'd
probably love this but I'm terrified of
heights so I don't love it what's wrong
with you four batteries every baby
foreign
[Music]
it's just an expression what do you say
buddy
[Music]
okay get you back in your luggage
[Applause]
[Music]
so Riley how was the first day of school
fine I guess
did you guys pick up on that
something's wrong signaled the husband
oh she's looking at us what did she say
oh sorry sir no one was listening is it
garbage night uh we left the toilet seat
up what is it woman what
[Music]
I'm Joy this is sadness that's anger
this is disgusting and that's fear we're
Riley's emotions
these are Riley's memories they're
mostly happy you'll notice not to brag I
wanted to maybe hold one what happened
sadness she did something to the memory
is everything okay I don't know
more memories
can I say that curse word now
[Music]
nothing's working why isn't it working
we have a major problem oh I wish Joy
was here we can fix this we just have to
get back to headquarters that's
long-term memory you could get lost in
there think positive okay I'm positive
you will get lost in there
was it a bear there are no bears in San
Francisco I saw a really Airy guy you
look like a bear
[Music]
[Applause]
this place is huge imagination land you
know what dream Productions rainbow
unicorns she's right there I loved you
in fairy dream Adventure part seven okay
bye I love you
can't focus on what's going wrong
there's always a way to turn things
around
[Music]
congratulations San Francisco give
everyone Pizza
[Music]
Mommy here we come
oh it's you you're gonna get me in
trouble daddy someone could hear me I
wish someone wanted to hear me other
than you okay
[Music]
I know I'm not supposed to love music no
music no music
[Music]
but my great grandma Coco's father was
the greatest musician of all time
Ernesto De La Cruz one day he left with
his guitar and never returned no my
family thinks music is a curse great
great grandfather none of them
understand me
I'm supposed to play music all right
who's in there I'm sorry
I'm just dreaming
[Music]
your family
I know your great great grandpa I'll get
you to him what are you doing I'm
walking like a skeleton no skeletons
don't walk like that that's how you walk
no I don't when there's no one left in
the living world who remembers you you
disappear from this world but you can
change that we gotta find my freak your
grandpa you gotta do it by Sunrise what
happens at Sunrise you'll be stuck here
forever
[Music]
I'm a big fan
never forget how much your family loves
you it's almost Sunrise one cannot deny
one is meant to
oh
that's you I am terribly allergic but
Dante doesn't have any hair and I don't
have a nose and yet here we are
[Music]
what
is this place
what's your name honey uh I'm Joe I
teach Middle School band got it go for
it
[Music]
today started out as the best day of my
life
back here tonight First shows at seven
yes
yes I did it I got the gig
must have been sudden for you
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
is this Heavens no it's the great before
this is where new Souls get their
personalities quirks and interest before
they go to Earth meet 22. I don't want
to go to first stop fighting this I
don't wanna
okay look I already know everything
about Earth and I don't want anything to
do with it you're missing out on the
joys of life like uh Pizza I can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch
see
okay I get it
wow it's my life
is all this living really worth dying
for
foreign
[Music]
what is it 151 000 Souls going through
the grape Beyond every day and I count
every single one of them
that counts off
did you hear that what was that you're
what yeah I just I heard someone say
hello yeah there's a lot of fish here
anybody literally anybody could have
just said hello there where am I looking
there oh hi I'm Dory yeah well we're
your parents hi
[Music]
where did you see them last I forgot
I was looking for something and I okay
totally get it date night
I suffer from short-term memory loss it
runs in my family
at least I think it does where are they
hurry there you are look out oh look at
this
our friend now take it into whatever
this place is it's a fish hospital I
feel fantastic
[Applause]
dude
names Hank I have to find my family
that's a hard one kid well I guess
you're stuck here you're not helping
them friends of things I lost my family
that is so sad not a great swimmer our
friend is in there lost alone Bailey
you've got to use your echo location I
feel stupid poor babies let me get that
for you
she should just pick two and let's go
Dad what I'm kidding
I get the feeling they're shushing us
for a reason like something with one big
eye tentacles and a Snappy thing well
that's very specific but something like
that
all right
Somewhere Out There is my family I can't
find them on my own
I don't want to be touched
sorry that's okay everybody does it
nothing to be ashamed of
I trust Becky you trust Becky Becky's
eating a cup wow
keep swimming mom dad does this mean we
have to say goodbye to Dory I don't know
why I thought I could do this Dory you
are about to find your parents and when
you do that you'll be home
sea lions they are natural Predators
they could pounce at any moment my don't
you worry
don't you worry about one thing
[Music]
I thought we were gonna go you heard
your mother trampolini
superheroes are illegal we want to fight
bad guys it defines who I am we're not
saying you have what someone on TV said
it I was approached by this Tycoon must
to talk about hero stuff help me bring
supers back into the sunlight we need
Blaster girl bye sweetie I'll watch the
kids no problem
that's not the way you're supposed to do
it dad they want us to do it I don't
know that way why would they change math
math is math math is math all over
Dusseldorf diesels are dozing your
Island's so heavy
[Music]
closing I couldn't have done this if you
hadn't taken over so well I've got to
succeed so she can succeed Bob
that's freaky but I can't keep giving
him cookies
done properly parenting is a heroic act
done properly
[Music]
all right let's get you plugged in
wiffy or is it wifey why don't we just
go in
[Music]
or
online
we are going to the internet super
excited just one minor thing what is the
internet
holy cow look at all this stuff
congratulations you're a winner really
these 10 child stars went to prison
number six will Amaze you that sounds
interesting come on
redirecting to eBay ladies and gentlemen
the next item up a black velvet painting
of a sorrowful kitten
it's like it's looking into my soul yeah
that one's Really Gonna haunt me for a
while
whoa games pancake
milkshake I'm awake is pancake milkshake
milkshake I'm starting to understand why
people like this game very Zen milkshake
[Music]
let's speed it up pancake pancake
pancake pancake pancake pancake pancake
thank you eat little buddy uh Ralph you
might want to try feeding the kitty for
a little while no the kitty gets the
milkshake The Bunny Gets the pancake
silly
[Music]
foreign